there's a lot of talk at the top hey
guys I'm Abbi start welcome to Abby's
kitchen and today I started up with my
friends a flat out flatbread who
sponsored this video to share with you
some of my favorite ways to get in my
vegetables tacos oh yes these Buffalo
cauliflower and chickpea tacos are so
amazing they're basically the lovechild
between my two favorite comfort foods
tacos and buffalo wings blessed they are
practiced plant-based protein
antioxidants and lots of fiber so the
key to a good taco is to start with an
awesome taco shell and there's really
two types of people in this world when
it comes to tacos hard taco people and
soft taco people I'm partial to the hard
tacos but don't worry I've got a really
great trick here help you make your
tacos either way whether you go hard or
soft you definitely want to make sure
that your taco shells are both delicious
and nutritious and while corn tortillas
are traditional there's not a whole lot
going on from a nutrition perspective so
I always use plaited folded flat breads
for my taco shells and I know you guys
have seen me use these before for making
amazing grilled cheese and I love them
because I've got 7 grams each fiber and
protein plus Omega 3 in every 90
calories flatbread and I know I know we
don't really look exactly like taco
shells yet but your cannot stick around
because I've got a sneaky little hack
for that
let's make tough first I'm going to make
an easy cilantro-lime crema in a small
food processor item buying from coconut
yogurt cilantro lime juice cumin salt
and pepper
next in a large bowl I mixed together
some whole wheat flour water garlic
powder salt and pepper add in my
cauliflower florets and toss them until
they're coated in the batter then I
spread them out onto a baking sheet and
bake for about 15 minutes at 450 degrees
while that's baking I mixed together
some hot sauce olive oil and lemon juice
I flipped the cauliflower add in my
chickpeas to the baking sheet and toss
everything with the hot sauce roast for
an additional 15 minutes or until
everything is crispy and golden brown
now let's get the most important parts
of tacos for my hard taco fans
I cut the flat out folded in half filled
two circles and brush them with some
more hot sauce on one side
nestled them between some muffin tins
and pop them in the oven for about 8 to
10 minutes or until the edges crisp up
and brown remove them from the oven and
allow them to cool and for my soft taco
friends I'm just going to brush the flat
edge with more hot sauce and lightly pan
fry them to warm them up and gently
caramelize the bread to assemble I layer
the taco shells with some cabbage our
taco filling avocado crema and some
cilantro to finish
[Music]
so there you have it a delicious vegan
taco recipe that is packed with fiber
and protein and thank you again to flat
it for sponsoring this video if you want
to find some spots near you check out
flat out finder calm today and of course
if you love this recipe be sure to give
it a thumbs up leave me a comment below
about whether you are teen soft taco or
teen hard taco subscribe to the channel
and I'll see you next time on a beach
kitchen bye
[Music]